rires mais surtout avec tout le monde
voilà le message que délivre
l'association karnas dhj les sous bois
rires pour aller mieux ou pour atténuer
la douleur marie thérèse rose présidente
de l'association donne les clés de la
thérapie par le rire
laurie reproduit des tas de substance et
de neurotransmetteurs et d'euphorisants
qui permettent effectivement de lutter
contre le stress mais pas que ça ça peut
permettre aussi d'avoir une même une
meilleure digestion
parce que quand vous riez par exemple
c'est un exemple beaucoup et elle bouge
donc elle fait une sorte de massage sur
l'estomac l'intestin et le foie donc ça
fait des organes qui vaut mieux
fonctionner leur ira il est
indispensable à la ville pour marie
thérèse le rire joue sur la qualité de
vie et le bien-être psychologique mais
il est aussi vecteur d'un lien social
maryse rohff et donne des cours de yoga
du rire un rire communicatif et même
contagieux et vous allez faire comme si
vous rugissiez comme un lion en sortant
lagord lalande en exemple le yoga du
rire c'est d'abord la prise de
conscience de son corps et de sa
verticalité sans jugement simplement un
ressenti de son corps de toutes les
parties de son corps celui qui est
vraiment et que nous faisons
régulièrement parce que je tiens le
faire c'est vraiment le rire du d'union
parce qu'il exprime vraiment tout
c'est vraiment la rolls royce du rire
aujourd'hui les français de moins en
moins en moyenne une minute par jour en
2015 contre une vingtaine en 1940 il ne
tient plus qu'à vous d'inverser cette
tendance en le propre agent